This is Devon
They called Devon a miracle child
He survived a rare birth defect that almost cost him his life
In grade school he was bullied because of a hearing impairment
He used sports to express himself in
High school davonne only weighed 140 pounds, but that didn't stop
The kids got heart
And this is Marshall
Marshall was always playing sports going up and loved to ride a board or two
In high school Russia became a football star
He would be he was prone
to do had an inner feeling or
Devon balled out at Central High School in Baton Rouge
But no one offered him a scholarship
Instead he walked on a Southern University where his dad played
Russia was Allstate in Florida had colleges lining up
So he chose judging where more creeks and the dogs had an opening
Kick after Keith he was automatic
By seeing you
Marshall was one of the best kickers in the country and
unlike other kickers rushar didn't shy away from contact
Devon didn't start in college it took every chance to prove himself
especially in the big games like going up against Georgia in 2015
That's when I met Devon
And that's how I'm in Washington
I just seen this guy
I
heard the band playing I
Was thinking I have to get up my team need me I have to get up
But nothing was budget, so I was just laying there
Southern flaire on the field in the Georgia athletic training staff first once there the near sideline to look after
Exit saw the blow happened
His first one there as to what was going on and he said he couldn't feel anything or didn't move
I couldn't I couldn't move anything, but my hands
That's a scary feeling
collision on the return
Right side your screen number 33 meets up with number 13 collided at the end of the play with the guy
Who's been the best tackler on Georgia's kickoff coverage to the kicker?
Marshall Morgan
Once I started talking to the sideline. I look back and he's not getting up. That's when I started kind of freaking out
Things are going through my mind like it could have been this this what I hope he moves like because I first he wasn't
moving at all Devon gales sophomore from Baton Rouge out of Central High School
Mark Richt has made his way over
Scary moment yep
Broadcaster came on and said that we have Devon Gill Southern University wide receiver number 33 down on the field
Of course my heart dropped to
See my son laying there on that field
Helpless not being able to get up. It was it was heartbreaking I
Felt the pain hurt because I wasn't there
and they're gonna cart the young man off the field our prayers go out that everything's okay with Devon gales I
was around 5/8
158 so out pretty small, but I was still being in the heart
It was a freak accident I
Actually hit him I
See Devon she's running towards me and so in my mind
I'm thinking this guy's coming to lay me out
So I just tried to get a good base and just kind of almost absorb it
I wasn't looking to lay anyone out the way we collided
It was this tragic
I mean
right at the point of impact Devon actually lowered his head down and
soared the blow and the problem with that is when you lower your head your spine becomes straight and his source of force like a
column so we knew he had significant spotters at that point I
Would just telling myself, I'm gonna be okay, I'm gonna be okay, but my parents. I lose they were worried about me
The doctors told me I was paralyzed
One side of me wanted to cry the other side gym one stay strong for my family
He was able to move his hands. He wasn't able to move his fingers, but at the same time nothing
he couldn't feel anything from his chest all the way down to his toes the doctor told us that there was a
50-50 chance that he could walk again, I had to get a
metal rod the back of my neck with screws I
Started here. He could be paralyzed. I was like. This is way too serious like this can't be happening
I'm thinking you know his parents are gonna hate me that everyone's gonna think I'm I'm the guy that
just just
Paralyzed the Vong kind of thing right then I was like I need to go see this kid and I need to go see his
Parents, and I felt like I'd uh like apologize
The next day he was undergoing some surgeries at the time I
Go to the hospital
And I kind of walk up and I see his mom we wrapped our arms around each other and just started crying
I'm trying to hold this big guy up and I'm like okay, baby. You know it's okay. You know
I just kinda had to comfort him and let him know that we don't blame you for any of this and I don't want you
to blame yourself some families it could have been the totally opposite and
they're just the most loving and
Forgiving and I mean what's welcoming family ever
This is just something that happens in football well
That's a heavy burden to carry and as much as I could have spoken to him in his ear
I knew that he still had that blame on himself you
Know he had concern
If you're in the middle of a play like that you can't help, but be affected by it in some way
It could have gone either way. I wish it didn't happen either of us
Yes, yeah
Because of the Vaz injury the Gaels family life actually changed just like that
Around my neck
Hey, what smell my brick nope
Here's a guy that's been through a
Rough injury that you know him and his family probably gonna need some help
Financially and there's an opportunity to do that and I'm I'm calling all dogs to do that coach, Richt
He said regardless of the color of devons jersey right now. He's one of us or whatever you need he said
You have it
Bad news didn't have a spine injury
Hospital and talk with everybody we felt stronger this Shepherd was the best facility for him in the nation to go to
We're forcing us right down the street from the University of Georgia, so it was a nice fit
I have my little moments
Every day I just wish I'm up and doing something like just to do
You say dad I'm a walk again, and I gotta believe it
I can't help daughter my child and and not me and my wife believe that he will I
Miss football a lot I
Had one day not like man. I wish I'd I wouldn't hit Marshall
But you can't redo what's been done?
After Devon was injured
I would always talk to Marshall just to check on him because I know once
You're involved in the situation we heard someone is gonna. Go through your mind
you could tell that it weighed on him a little bit all the stuff that was going on in my mind I
Was still thinking about Devon?
As I ride the season out I'm getting updates about Devon recovery
Every time I get an update it's more positive. There's just a big motivator like I was playing for him I
Wanted to make him proud
George Allegiant
You know he really wanted to get a chance to meet Devon face-to-face, and you know it's Justin ended his talk to him
We decided to invite Devon his family down to one of our football games
That was the first time I met washing impression
Giggling in real life isn't that your phone? That's when to kill the blame kind of just switch
From there. I was always trying reach out to him and you do the same
He wished me. Good luck before games. It was just nice to be able to talk to him. That's really what started this relationship
And you just hit it off from there
He wanted to
Be there with me to his journey
Because it's not just mine as he is too
He's strong as now I don't know if I'd be able to be as positive as he is
Him going through one of the toughest things that a human could go through
A lot of times people visit, but then as time goes on you know they sort of drift away
But Marshall will kept in touch with the family, and they developed a strong friendship
When something happens
then that magnitude you you tend to get to know people a little bit more because you're living through the pain and the
corporal victory in the end
And I just like hanging around him hanging out with them
He's just inspiration
I'm here for you. You're here for me
Just like a normal brother would do for your liver
They bonded with this injury. It's something that we may not understand, but it's something between the two of them
Other than my wife's family you know my first invites Madison nas wedding was Devon
They're meant a lot to me
And washa was like can I push the bunny, and I'm like dude you're getting married
You're supposed to be standing there waiting to walk in oh no no I want to do this myself. I
Got to push him down, and you know
let people kind of just see how he is family I
Felt a part of the family
I am part of the family
I posted a video of devons first time being in a set of robotic legs
Davonne always said he will walk again. I said even if it's not on his own. Just yet. This is just a small stepping-stone
When it first happened that's kind of what I was praying for it to see that he couldn't move it all much at first and
to see him like that that's unbelievable I
Totally believe I'm gonna walk again in time better than I welcome before
Davonne kinda made me realize that you know there's more to life than football
Really, it's about relationships
He is the most positive
Inspirational person I've ever met
I'm grateful that I was able to have a bond with him
Fate brought us together
B-but another life until my future
It made us brothers
You